i consider it an honor to make this
video for the mom congress and first i
just want to talk a little bit about
what khan academy is some of you may
have heard of it and then we could talk
about how we can work together to
improve
learning everywhere for everyone so khan
academy it is most known and it's all
available at khan academy khan
academy.org
and it's most known for a collection of
videos that i started making for my
cousin in new orleans that's where i
grew up as well and those videos there's
over 3000 now and they cover everything
from basic math all the way to college
level science and economics and history
so we have those and they've been
watched over 100 million times but
that's just part of khan academy
complementing the videos or the videos
complementing them we also have
exercises i'll draw someone exercising
right over here
we have exercises and these essentially
allow students to get practice and
feedback on what they need to learn and
then it progresses them as they show
proficiency and mastery in different
topics and the videos and the exercises
are connected if you don't understand
how to do something there will be steps
and hints and then the videos are there
to complement it and all of this is
being all of this is in kind of a
framework of a lot of data and that data
is being logged for the student's
benefit the system can make use of that
data to determine what is the most
appropriate content for the student and
it can also be shared with
what we call coaches
and these coaches can be anyone from the
student's older sibling to their teacher
to a family member like i was working
with my cousins or their mothers
or their
or their mothers
and then all of this we also have a
whole series of what for lack of a
better word what we could call game
mechanics that we use to try to motivate
and make sure and and encourage what we
think are good behaviors of perseverance
and engagement on on the part of the
students so this is game mechanics so to
at least make it at least as engaging as
some as as other things that may not as
because it may not be as constructive
for a student's uh academic well-being
now with that out of the way and i
encourage you we're a not-for-profit
501c3.org
501c3 no one owns us and our mission
really is a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere now that out of the
way i want to think about how this could
be relevant for moms and obviously
there's one direct point of relevance is
that all of the children who use khan
academy they all
they have parents and and the parents
can get involved by being their coaches
by encouraging students to use it and to
really keep track of things and and and
provide the things that frankly we're
going to try to get better and better
become have more content richer content
more engaging content but there's
nothing beats that human in the room
that can get the student to the next
level
but i'll say go take taking it even a
step further than that instead of just
using khan academy as a resource for
students and then having maybe parents
be coaches i'll say take a step further
if you really want to change the culture
in your household or in your community
or in your school i would say that the
moms themselves the moms themselves
should start trying out all of this
stuff and make you
make each each of you should find other
mothers who are doing it and be each
other's coaches and let your student let
your children be your coaches so that
they see it isn't just a parent telling
students to do something but by setting
an example by mother saying hey you know
what i also want to revisit algebra or
learn algebra or finally learn calculus
or revisit biology or whatever it is
it's probably the strongest signal
stronger than any signal you can do to
tell your parent your student to
actually work on something so hopefully
you guys give it a shot all free all
not-for-profit millions of kids are
already working on it and check out our
site it seems like it's it's really
doing some some interesting things for a
lot of students and some schools there's
over 10 000 schools around the country
are adopting it and if you want your
school to explore it there's a teacher
toolkit on the site that start that
documents how it's being used in
different use cases and so you could
share it with your local communities but
the one thing that i would love to see
more than anything else that i think
really could change the culture in
households is if we have moms across
america starting to get
pretty good at mathematics